a transgender rapist Isla Bryson has
been jailed for eight years for attacks
on two women while they were still a man
this is what the judge had to say in the
last few minutes
having regard to the whole circumstances
of the case in particular the gravity of
the charges
only a custodial sentence is appropriate
it is necessary to punish you and to
seek to deter you and others from
behaving in this way and in particular
to protect the public from you
having considered the pattern of
offending the gravity of your crimes and
the insights in the various reports
I consider that the question of how best
to protect the public does arise
I am concerned to ensure that the public
is adequately protected against serious
harm from you
when you are released from prison
it is plain that you present a
particularly significant risk to any
woman with whom you form a relationship
having reflected carefully in all the
circumstances in my judgment the normal
period of license would not be enough to
protect the public
from serious harm from you
accordingly I consider that the
custodial sentence in your case should
be by way of an extended sentence
in all the circumstances I impose the
following sentence
on charges one and three taken together
a sentence you to a cumulo extended
sentence of 11 years
with a custodial term of eight years and
an extension period of three years for
the duration of which you will be under
license unconditions fixed by the
Scottish ministers